en passant du burkini à la pma et au
mariage pour tous ou encore en faisant
le bilan des manuels maquereau en
dressant la menace de jean-luc mélenchon
les sujets et les critiques n'ont pas
manqué lundi 23 mai lors de la venue de
marion maréchal à versailles la
vice-présidente de reconquête est venu
soutenir les candidats dans les yvelines
aux législatives on ne soutient pas que
les candidats qui peuvent
potentiellement transformer l'essai et
devenir député se trouve que par
ailleurs c'est vrai que les yvelines et
en particulier ses dix circonscriptions
sont des circonscriptions sur lesquels
nous avons un potentiel électoral non
négligeable et pour un peu que les
électeurs de reconquête
du premier tour de ces élections
présidentielles se mobilisent en masse
eh bien nous pourrions créer la surprise
à versailles eric zemmour a réalisé une
véritable percée au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle avec 18,48 %
des voix c'est donc dans une salle
comble de 300 personnes environ que
mario maréchal était attendu je suis fan
déjà de marion maréchal et puis étant
mené à versailles ça me tenait à coeur
de soutenir les candidats aux
législatives
ça fait super plaisir d'une foule de
voir une femme s'y engager si convaincu
et qui a un vrai projet pour la france
nouvelle nous a complètement redonner
espoir et envie de croire en la
politique ce qu'on avait perdu à la
suite des élections je crois que
l'avenir de la france est tout tracé
avec marion les 12 candidats reconquête
des yvelines étaient également présents
pour accueillir leur vice présidente
aujourd'hui reconquête c'est le vrai
discours de droite qui n'a pas oublié
une partie des convictions de la droite
à savoir la partie des libertés la
liberté d'entreprendre le courage de
revendiquer nos racines
judéo-chrétiennes l'ensemble des
candidats sont ensuite montés sur scène
pour entamer la marseillaise puis marion
maréchal est allé à la rencontre des
participants